اكدت مصادر العربيه ان نادي النصر السعودي
تعاقد مع البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
وذلك لمده موسمين وبدات مسيره رونالدو في
سبورتنج لشبونه لعب بعدها لانديه مانشستر
يونايتد وريال مدريد ويوفنتوس قبل ان يعود
الى مانشستر في ولايه ثانيا ومن ثم التوجه
للعاصمه السعوديه الرياض مع النصر وقد حصد
رونالدو مع البرتغال لقابين كاس اوروبا
2016 ودوري الامم الاوروبيه 2019 كما توج
بخمسه القاب لدوري ابطال اوروبا ويعد
الهداف التاريخي للبطوله
عبر الهاتف من الرياض عادل البطيه لاعب
كره القدم السابق اهلا بك معنا استاذ عادل
ما اهميه انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو لنادي
النصر السعودي
العربيه
بالتاريخ من خلال المقدمه او لاعب تاريخ
في كره القدم احد اهم الاساطير كره القدم
في العقده للسابقين
اضافه كبيره
لدورينا على يعني اولا على المستوى
التسويق والتشويق ومن ثم الناحيه الفنيه
همم هناك من يرى انه احيانا انه همم
كريستيانو 37 سنه لكن لا نحكم على
كريستيانو من خلال السنه الاخيره هو هداف
في كل مناسبه وما زال يعني يتفوق على كثير
من اللاعبين في العالم في نسبه التهديد
وغيرها امورنا نعتقد انها كثير
طيب من الناحيه التقنيه الفنيه ما ابرز
النواحي التي سيستطيع رونالدو ان يغطيها
في كره القدم السعوديه من خلال نادي النصر
تحديدا
يعني اولا خلينا نقول
فنيه
وهو يضل حتى الخانه تغيرت بالنسبه له وفق
عمره وما زال يؤكد انه اسم كبير في خارطه
كره القدم العالميه اثنين هو اسم كبير لما
تكلم اليوم وانا اعتقد انه كل وسائل
الاعلام في العالم بتتكلم عن توقيع
كريستيانو خلينا نقول لهذه النصر ولي
الدوري السعودي وهو يعني رقم واحد بالنسبه
لان انه كان سمعت كره السعوديه ان يكون
كريستيانو واحد اللاعبين اللي يشارك في
الدوري المحلي السعودي ثلاثه في اكثر من
اسم سيتردد يعني في نجوم كثير لو سالتهم
قبل فتره انه يوقع لي في الدوري السعودي
يفكر اكثر من مره اليوم همم كريستيانو
بيكون وسيله جلد للاعبين
للرعيات ولي امور ان اعتقد كثيره اليوم كل
مباراه في الدوري السعودي على الاقل تشوف
منها ملخصات في كثير من همم دول العالم
عشان كده انا اقول هي صفقه بصراحه محسوبه
وملعوبه من كافه النواحي احيانا اللاعب
تجيبه او تستقبل لاعب من اجل الامور فنيه
لكسب مباراتهم
اليوم كريستيانو مكسب مو بس داخل المستطيل
الاخضر دل على كافه الجوانب بالنسبه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
تشجيعه كما قلنا سابقا لاعبين اخرين
للانضمام الى نوادر سعوديه
وكذلك من خلال العمل همم يعني مستمر على
اعلاء شان كره القدم والرياضه بشكل عام في
السعوديه ضمن مشروع متكامل همم الاهداف
والمعالم وليس فقط عبر استئذاب لاعب اجنبي
من هنا او من هناك مهمه
المشروع اللاعب هذا بيكون مشروع الكره
السعوديه في كافه الجوانب
همم ناحيه فنيه بالفيديو اخرى كل لاعب
اليوم اللي بيكون عنده استعداد يتواجد بل
يعني تكون حافز كبير الكثير من اللاعبين
على مستوى العالم انه ممكن يجيء ياخذ
تجربه في الكره السعوديه انا شوف انسان
طاهر انتظر الاسابيع القادمه تيجي صداها
اكبر انا اجذب ان هذا الموضوع باكد لنا
خلال يعني اسابيع قليله من مسيره يعني هو
الان يوقع في الفتره الشتويه امامنا سته
شهور لانهاء لانتهاء الموسم الرياضي السته
شهور دي فيها اعلان عن الكره السعوديه
اكثر من سنوات
لكن اكيد ان الدوري بيشعر به الاخرون بشكل
اكبر
يعني همم مشجع مفيد او بجانب معين ربما
همم حساس لبعض اللاعبين السعوديين
لا لا بالعكس انا اعتقد اللعب مع
كريستيانو او امام كريستيانو هو عمري يسعد
اي لاعب ان يشارك في هذه المباراه مباشره
تتجه لهذه واللاعب احيانا يحتاج انه يكون
تحت المجهر بالذات اللاعب البارز يعني
بيكون محفز حتى للاعب السعودي من ناحيه
فنيه ان اشارك في مباراه والكاميرات
والاعين كلها تتابع بل يمكن يكون لها اثر
ايجابي حتى في احتراف اللاعبين السعوديين
اللي احنا مفتقدين اللي احتراف هو خارج
المملكه كل هذه الامور ترى ايجابيه الناس
تنظرها ممكن البعض يرى انها ناحيه فنيه في
داخل الملعب او في يلعب 15 مباراه في
الدور الثاني او 30 في مباراه في الموسم
لا لا الامر ابعد من ذلك كثير اثارها على
اللاعب اللي مع همم كريستيانو في فريقه
واللاعبين الاخرين بل حتى في ايام لما
تشوف انه في ايام الفيفا عندما يغادر مثلا
لو كان مستمر مع منتخب بلاده او عدد في
ايام الفيفا الناس يقول لك غادر من الدوري
السعودي يلعب في منتخب بلاده كل هذا اثر
اثر جيد حتى على مستوى الرعايه وهو يعني
اكيد ان الدوري بيكون اكثر قيمه اكيد ان
الرعاه بيكون بينهم منافسه عشان يكونون
احد همم الرعاه للدوري السعودي كل هذه
الامور نعتقد نواحي ايجابيه كبيره لكرتنا
همم يعني اكبر من العقم نفسه او حتى لو
كان المبلغ كبير الا انه النفع المتاتي
على النادي وعلى الرياضه السعوديه
والعربيه والاسيويه همم اكبر من اي رقم
عشان الاستاذ طاهر عندما تريد ان تستثمر
تضع مبلغ هناك من يقول مثلا المبلغ كبير
لكن الاهم العائد ايش احيانا لما تستثم
تضع مبلغ كبير المتوقع عائده اكبر اليوم
عائده مو بس من ناحيه الماديه في جوانب
اخرى كثيره عشان كذا الاستثمار الصح حتى
وانغلى ثمنه ان اعتقد يزيد مع الوقت وهذا
يعني هذا المؤمن والمتوقع باذن الله تعالى
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه من الرياض
عادل البطيء لاعب كره القدم السابق تحيات
اليك
قبل 37 ربيعا ولد باحد احياء جزيره ماذر
البرتغاليه وبها انطلقت مسيرته الكرويه
جعل الجد والمثابره وسيله لتحقيق احلامه
فكان لهما اراد
كريستيانو رونالدو بدا من فريق نانسي
عجرم
فكان النجم الاول في الفريق بل في العالم
حين منال جائزه الكره الذهبيه سنه 2008
رئيس ريال مدريد
لم يرضى بغير استخدام رونالدو مهما كلفه
الثمن في عام 2009 البرتغالي اصبح اغلى
لاعب في تاريخ المستديره بصفقه انتقال
بلغت قيمتها 80 مليون جنيه استرليني
في ريال مدريد تعلق رونالدو فاز بكل
الالقاب الممكنه اضاف الى خزينته الشخصيه
اربع كرات ذهبيه لتصبح خمسا في المجموعه
رونالدو عرج على فريقه يوفنتوس الايطالي
سنه 2018 ثم عاد الى مانشستر يونايتد من
جديد سنه 2021 على مستوى المنتخب ايضا نجح
في كسب رهان وتوج بلقب كاس الامم
الاوروبيه سنه 2016
ودوريه الامم الاوروبيه سنه 2019 رونالدو
انتقل الى فريق النصر السعودي في صفقه قوه
الدوري السعودي في انتظار تالق على
الملاعب السعوديه مثل ما فعل على الصعيد
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
بلال البوجداني العربيه
البيان البريطاني الان يحدد ضروره اجراء
فحوص الركاب فحوص كوفد 19 قبل الصعود في
الطائره لكل المتوجهين من الصين الى
انجلترا وبالتالي تنضم الى دول اخرى مثل
فرنسا وايطاليا واسبانيا اعلنت ذلك اليوم
همم والفحص يجب ان يكون ماخوذ
يعني قبل يومين كحد اقصى من الرياض مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي مجددا في هذه
الساعه معنا لاطلاعنا على ردود الافعال
حول انضمام او اتمام صفقه كريستيانو
رونالدو مع نادي النصر السعودي ما الذي
يقوله السعوديون عندك حول هذه الصفقه
في الحقيقه طاهر لم يكن السعوديون فقط
المتواجدون في الرياض او في السعوديه بشكل
عام هم من احتفوا بهذا الصفقه ورحبوا بها
ولكن حتى عدد من المقيمين في السعوديه
الكل من محبي كره القدم في السعوديه وحتى
خارج رحبوا بشكل كبير جدا في هذه الصفقه
البعض نزل الى الشوارع لي يتبادل الاحاديث
وايضا همم ياخذ الاخبار وهمم بعض ايضا
يحتفل في هذه الاماكن التيما النصراويه
منهم ولكن همم التقيت بعدد كبير جدا من
الجمهور بمختلف الانديه في السعوديه رحبوا
بشكل كبير جدا في هذه الصفقه وقالوا انها
اضافه كبيره لاضعك بالصوره مباشره ننتقل
الى الشارع همم مباشره الى الجمهور اليوم
كيف تشوف صفقه كريستيانو رونالدو الاعلان
همم عن هذه الصفقه اضافه همم اضافه
كريستيانو رونالدو ماذا سيقدم كمشجع كيف
تشوف هذه الصفحه او الشيء مرحبا تقول
المشاهدين صفقه انتقال رونالدو مكسب كبير
الكره السعوديه لاعب كبير وانتقل نادي
كبير همم في ظل التطورات التي تعيشها
المملكه والرؤيه التي يقود الامير محمد بن
سلمان لحفظ الله شيء كبير يعني لاعب له
وزنه في الكره العالميه كذا الدوري
السعودي راح يوصل الى كل البيوت في العالم
وشيء جميل يعني جدا تقريبا مشجع اخر قبل
ايام كنا في مباراه النصر والهلال كانت
مباراه قويه وكل شيء هدا ليس السعوديه
ولكن ااه على مستوى الاقليمي وحتى الدولي
اليوم كريستيانو وحيتواجد في الدوري
السعودي كيف تشوف هذه الاضافه بالاضافه
لانه دوري اصلا قوي من من السابق فكيف
رونالدو ممكن ان يضيف الى الدوري والله
الصراحه همم كريستيانو رونالدو انا صراحه
اني قائمين على نجاح هذه الصفقه الصراحه
شعور انه كان نادي النصر شعور لا يوصف
لاعب بحجم كريستيانو رونالدو يكون متواجد
في الدوري وادي هذا بيضيف قيمه كبيره
للدوري السعودي بشكل عام اكثر من نادي
النصر شكرا ايضا طاهر احد ال ال المقيمين
في هذا انت بمصر صح طيب انت انت على طول
شوفنا نتكلم عن كريستيانو وجيت كيف شايف
هذه الصفقه بص على الرغم يعني وان انا
تشجيع الكامل لليو ميسي بس يعني كريستيانو
رونالدو اسطوره كبيره اضافه كبيره جدا
يعني
الدوري السعودي يعني
اسطوره بالحجم ده شايفه ان هو يجب يعني
همم
دعايه كبيره جدا للمملكه واتمنى ان هو
يكون يعني اضافه كبيره لفريق النصر
كلمنا عن هذه الصفقه كيف انت تشوفها كم
مشجع همم واضافه كريستيانو رونالدو الى
قائمه المحترفين في الدوري السعودي
باجلبوي بنقل بنصراوي من كريستيانو
بالسعوديه ما طلعت في القنوات الا يوم
فازت على الارجنتين كاس العالم
والان اضافه كريستيانو اضافه كريستيانو
وبيصير شيء كبير يعني كل الدول اللي بره
راح تسمع عنك كل سنه الفريق السعودي في
النصر تنتظر من ناحيه تسويقيه يعني
تسويقيه وكان همم الدول الثانيه راح يعني
اللي ما قدرت السعوديه راح تتجس السعوديه
شكرا
الهلاليين مراحب بهذه الصفقه نظرا لقوه
كريستيانو رونالدو وايضا شعبيه الجارفه في
همم السعوديه من قبل ان همم حتى يتم تداول
هذه الاخبار عن هذه الصفقه كريستيانو
رونالدو الذي متوقع ان يصل خلال ربما
الايام القليله القادمه لم يتم الاعلان
الرسميه ولكن ننتظر وصول كريستيانو
رونالدو وايضا هناك مناسبه مهمه ستقام في
يناير على همم هامش موسم الرياض حيث يلتقي
كريستيانو وفي اولى مهامه ربما في الرياض
ومع النصر ضد ليونيل ميسي في مباراه
لباريس سان جيرمان ضد نجوم النصر والهلال
الذي التي تنظمها هيئه الترفيه بالاضافه
الى همم هذه المباراه سيكون هناك بكل
تاكيد زخم كبير جدا يصاحب هذه المباراه
بعد وصول كريستيانو رونالدو ومواجهته همم
بشكل رسمي لفريقه الجديد النصر ضد ليونيل
ميسي في باريس سان جيرمان في الرياض
همم جميل جدا يعني انه هذا سيستقب ايضا ان
يلعب نجوم هارون كبار مثل ميسي امام
رونالدو عندما ينضم الى نادي النصر ونحن
سنتابع ذلك وسيكون همم اللعبه المزيد من
التشويق معهما ومع بقيه نجوم همم بدون شك
حدث همم تاريخي وصفقه همم رياضيه تاريخيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحرب